two weeks of evidence four days of jury
deliberation an 18 year old in the dock
for murder and finally the verdicts on
five counts in a trial which has gripped
america as to the fifth count of the
information gage gross croix we the jury
find the defendant kyle edward kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
carl rittenhouse faced a life sentence
and this the relief as he learned he was
free
there were times we doubted the case
there were times we were confident and
to say that we were relieved would be
a gross misunderstatement outside court
the divide this trial has exposed loud
and angry
have a gun and you come up on me and you
try to cost me i'm gonna use it that's
the way it goes
around the corner the great aunt of
anthony huber one of the two men killed
by kyle rittenhouse and speechless ma'am
can you give us a sense of how you're
feeling
but on the other side of court mr
rittenhouse is family spokesman i
believe it represents a chance for this
country to
to have some discussions about how this
spun so far off the rails but it was
always about self-defense it's a trial
which has touched on so many divisive
issues race gun laws disinformation
politics and it's exposed such differing
views about what is right and what is
wrong it's liberal against conservative
american against american and it's a
snapshot of these divided states
it all began last summer kenosha erupted
in black lives matter protests after the
shooting by police of black man jacob
blake carl rittenhouse traveled from
neighboring illinois to counter the
protests claiming he was there to
protect businesses and offer medical
help he was armed with an ar-15 assault
rifle we don't have non-lethal
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property
yes
this is the first man to be shot by mr
rittenhouse joseph rosenbaum part of the
black lives matter protest here kyle
rittenhouse is seen being chased by mr
rosenbaum a man nearby fires a handgun
into the air written house turns towards
the direction of gunfire mr rosenbaum
lunges at him and mr rittenhouse fires
four times hitting him in the head
he then runs down the road and trips as
he's chased by two other people anthony
huber is seen hitting him with a
skateboard ridden house shoots him from
the ground
a third man gage gross croots is also
shot and injured
the defense presented him as a man
protecting a community from a mob and
shooting in self-defense
and this was the portrait the jury
believed
absorbing it outside the uncle of jacob
blake the man shot by police last august
it was terrible i mean there's nowhere
in the world uh you can watch two young
men get murdered on video just like you
saw a little jake get shot seven times
and there's no justice and with such a
different reflection mark mccloskey who
brandished his gun outside his home last
year and now running for the senate i
think it's a great day for for america i
think it's a great day for individual
liberty
justice ran its course in court in
kenosha but it is a justice that's
caused a deep sense of american
self-reflection mark stone sky news in
kenosha wisconsin